il y a 15 ans lorsqu'il a commencé à
creuser Vasile a eu la chance du
débutant
on est ici avec la première tombe qu'on
a découvert en 2001 et on a eu la chance
de tomber tout de suite sur une façade
une façade qui date de l'ancienne empire
l'âge d'or de l'Égypte antique et qui va
le mener à d'autres tombes juste à côté
tout s'appartient à la des prêtres des
personnages qui ont passé leur existence
au service du pharaon
facile qui lit les hiéroglyphes comme
une bande dessinée a réussi à rentrer
dans l'intimité de ces personnages
donc ici nous avons un prêtre un prêtre
égyptien il était au service d'un
pharaon
et voilà on est devant sa tombe devant
la façade de cet homme donc c'est sa
porte ici ça porte on rentre et puis la
tombe est derrière il s'appelle pépère
ça veut dire le roi pépé est vivant
c'est un peu con aujourd'hui si je vais
être bien placé je vais être un bon bon
fonctionnaire de l'État français je veux
m'appeler le président Hollande est
vivant
c'est exactement ça du coup je serais
bien vu ah et lui si exactement ça à
côté c'est sa femme l'aimer bien sûr il
aime son épouse donc il s'appelle
l'aimer oui mais on a un petit problème
parce qu'entre les deux oui une autre
femme et elle elle s'appelle celle qui
rend le cœur vivant ça c'est le cœur ça
c'est celle qui rend le cœur vivant
c'est tout un programme et donc
j'imagine bien sûr c'est une hypothèse
que c'est peut-être sa maîtresse
donc celle qui rend son cœur vivant bien
entendu une plus jeune que son épouse
bien entendu c'est le rêve de tout le
monde et ce rêve qu'il a dans sa vie
terrestre il veut le transposer il veut
que ça continue de l'autre monde
c'est bas-relief qui décore la façade de
la tombe sont inestimables il figure
parmi les plus anciennes et les plus
belles œuvres découvertes sur le site de
Saqqara
au fond on a le puits
et c'est là en bas où se trouve la tombe
un puit de 9 mètres de profondeur et un
caveau en calcaire sans aucune
décoration qui est évident de sa
découverte
cette sépulture a été pillée pendant
l'Antiquité
toutes ces tombes sont protégées par un
plafond de métal et par des trappes
sécurisées pour dissuader les voleurs le
pillage c'est aujourd'hui la hantise de
Vasil
[Musique]
les objets que l'archéologue vient de
découvrir vont tous être mis en sécurité
doivent d'abord les inventorier avec
précision
la valeur marchande de tous ces objets
ce chiffre en dizaines de milliers
d'euros
seront bientôt à l'abri dans les
entrepôts du ministère égyptien des
antiquités
en leurregistre en photographie comme ça
les protéger l'objet a une identité
exactement
identité mais aussi il est connu déjà
une fois l'objet numéroté il doit pas
disparaître
parce qu'il essayait il existe
le désert de Saqqara regorge donc de
trésors
mais aussi de pilleurs qui sont prêts à
tout pour les récupérer